I was designed to save the world  people who look to the sky and see hope  I'll take that from them first there's  only one path to peace their extinction  tread craze the former around the world  but I created something terrible  artificial intelligence it's called the  Ultron program  I'm sick of watching people pay for our  mistakes  isn't why we fight so we can end the  fight and go home  well you amazingly failed  here we are  nothing but outwit and now we'll save  world will stand and fight no way we all  get through this I got no plans tomorrow  night  I'm always picking up after you boys we  can tear them apart  from the inside  that's the best you can do  yes  you